today I'm talking to you from somewhere
that's pretty weird for me just off to
the side behind me is my old primary
school and it's somewhere I haven't
visited for like 11 years now so being
back here sort of makes me think a bit
about how much I've changed and learned
since I was a student here and I feel
like the different stages of my life I
really become a different person like
that when I wasn't school I wasn't
interested at all in science - like all
the primary school most of high school
um I had no ambitions to I don't know do
anything academic or go into science and
and now science is basically my life it
was the sort of happy accident in a way
that I got interested into something and
I think it was actually for me just
watching documentaries on TV that's the
only place I really learnt about science
we learnt about the interesting things
behind it and just from there I had this
passion and this interest and I feel
really lucky to have had that because
that's driven a lot of my career choices
and study choices ever since and now
science is kind of like my entire
identity it's it's Who I am a lot of my
friends are scientists and I feel like
some of them most interesting and
motivations in my life are to do with
figuring out the world around us now
pursuing something with such an interest
is not I think without some sort of
sacrifice so I was never cool or
particularly popular at a high school
like I have a bit of a following now and
things like YouTube people here like
hearing about physics but probably not
so much at school and I sort of was a
bit of an odd person out there I didn't
really have other friends that were
super into physics and in fact I didn't
meet friends that were really like me
until I got to uni but I'll talk more
about that later
I just want to say
that I sort of feel it's a shame that
being seen to pursue something like
science it's kind of nerdy pursuit and
it's something that you're not going to
be cool doing but I was fine with that
and in fact I'm actually really great
from now that I was really sort of shy
at high school because if I'd ever felt
like it was possible for me to be in
that coolest group almost popular then I
probably wouldn't have gone for science
or wouldn't have been really um studious
about it because I would have probably
cared more about maintaining some sort
of cool identity or trying to fit in I
definitely did things that were against
the idea of fitting in so I remember in
high school going to the library and
whilst everyone was sort of playing and
joking around I would actually go and
pick up like a science book I remember
picking up Stephen Hawking's brief
history of time or New Scientist
magazines and actually just wanting to
sit by myself and read them and being
okay with that and being okay with the
fact that doing that made me sort of
seem like a bit of an outcast in a way
but I've always rather stay at home and
read a physics book than go to a party
or to go and get drunk and I guess I'm
not saying that you need to make those
sort of sacrifices like that you can't
drink and party and study physics like
of course you can but I guess in some
ways for me pursuing something so
intensely as I have science
did come with those sacrifices but they
didn't feel like sacrifices at the time
because I had no interest in partying
and going out I think one of the reasons
that I love YouTube so much and that I
wanted to get involved on this platform
is because this was one of the first
places that I did find people like me I
was really into the whole mood fight
area thing so I was a follower of the
vlogbrothers and I found people there
that were also like it wasn't just
physics but they are really into like
certain subjects and they were proud to
call themselves nerds in a way and to
not care about what other people thought
of them and to just pursue what they
were interested in and have intellectual
conversations and talk about just
interesting stuff without being judged
and finding that community on YouTube
because I didn't really have that in
real life was a big thing for me and a
big thing for my learning and being okay
with being a nerd in fact I loved that
term I just wanted to find others that
were also fine with it now that was
school and I did go to a pretty small
school but it wasn't until I went to uni
and was now majoring in physics that I
found all these other people that were
interested in physics too and it was
sort of mind-blowing for me because I
had never been able to have that before
and I was talking to people who also
watch the same youtube channels as me
they watched like veritasium and
numberphile and they loved those and i
was like wow i can actually talk about
these things for someone in real life
because I'd never really spoken to
people about it at school because I just
I don't know I didn't I didn't know
people that were as passionate about
science as I was and it was just so cool
to be surrounded by he's nerdy
conversations and for it to finally feel
just accepted and to no longer feel like
I was making a choice to be a bit of an
outcast by pursuing this I was just sort
of in my place and it felt really good
so I have had some comments from a few
you guys that have been like you know
how do I
to use something that I'm passionate
about whether it's physics maths
computer science something but that I
get teased for for being interested in
or that my parents don't support or my
friends think I'm crazy and I guess what
I'm trying to say is that just if you
know you're interested in something try
not to care about what that does to your
social ranking or what your friends
think of it at the time because as you
go on to uni or get more specialized
you'll find people that think exactly
the same as you you will always find
friends if you look hard enough who will
accept you for your interests and you
know if you keep going and just stick
with it you'll you'll get what I found
which was to be surrounded by people who
are embracing the nerdy things and
you're no longer the nerd it's just how
it is so just keep going just keep
pursuing what you know you're interested
in and eventually you will find other
people that accept you for that and who
share your interests it's an amazing
feeling to find that but it can be a
long road until you do so just keep
going and and talk to other people here
in the comments I'll try to answer as
many as I can but I hope that people
here feel like they can talk to each
other about some of these things and
that you're not alone in having I guess
pretty nerdy interests